The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome back.
Today, we will do two problems
involving many oscillators,
or at least several oscillators,
coupled to each other.
Now, you will not be surprised,
from past experience,
that in the situation
with several oscillators,
we are going to end up with
many equations and a lot
of grindy, tough
solving of equations.
Already, with a single
harmonic oscillator,
for example, with
damping, the equations
have been pretty horrendous.
Now, we considered a
couple of oscillators
with all the details, with
damping, driven, et cetera,
and it really
becomes complicated.
Now, what we are
trying to do by doing
problems is to get a feel,
an understanding what goes on
in a given situation, so one
wants to focus on new features
and try to simplify
the mathematics as
much as possible.
And so in the problems
are we doing now,
I am intentionally making them
even more ideal than before.
Consider the first problem.
Here is a highly
idealized system
which has 3 degrees of freedom.
What we have is we have a single
mass, 2m, two identical springs
attached to two
masses, each of mass m.
This is completely idealized.
We are assuming
there's no friction,
that these springs
are ideal springs.
In other words,
they're massless,
obey Hooke's laws
with constant k.
We are assuming the
system is constrained,
so it can only move
in one direction,
it can't move up and down
or in or out from the board.
So as I say, it's an
idealized situation.
And the question we want to
answer is, for such a system,
what are the normal
mode frequencies?
And you know from lectures
given by Professor Walter Lewin
that when you have coupled
oscillators, in this case, 3,
all right, one finds that there
are very special oscillations,
which we call normal mode
oscillations, in which
every part of the
system is oscillating
with the same
frequency and phase.
So first, we want to find
out for this system, what
are those three normal
mode frequencies?
And secondly, suppose
I take this system,
place these masses at some
arbitrary positions, some
maybe even moving, and
let go, how would I
predict where each mass
would be at some later time?
So those are the
two questions I want
to answer today
for this problem.
Now, in general, coupled
oscillator problems
are quite difficult.
But there are
situations in which
one can use logic
alone, well, logic
and our understanding
of coupled oscillators,
to do most of the
solution by hand-waving
and not do any calculations.
In this first example I'm
doing in this problem,
since the system has
a lot of symmetry,
I know from experience
that under those conditions
it might be possible to solve
this, as I say, by logic alone
and our understanding
of coupled oscillators.
So the issue is,
can I guess what
will be the motion
in the normal modes?
And the answer is, actually,
if you stop and think
for a second, at
least the first two
modes you can figure
out rather easily.
So here I'm showing
you schematically
what would be one of the
modes of oscillation,
one of the normal modes.
Imagine that I first
hold this mass fixed
and I displace these
symmetrically, one
to the right, one to
the left, and I let go.
What you will find
is, by symmetry,
this spring will always be
stretched by the same amount
as this is compressed, and
so the force on this mass
will be 0.
This spring will be pushing this
mass exactly by the same amount
as this one will be
pulling it and vice versa.
So there will never be any
net force on this mass,
and so they'll stay put.
And these two will now behave
as a simple harmonic oscillator
consisting of a spring attached
to a fixed wall and the mass m.
So that's what this
one will be doing,
and that's what
this will be doing.
It will be out of
phase by 180 degrees.
Or what one normally
says, it'll be in phase
but the amplitude will
be minus the other one.
This, by now, you've
had enough experience
and I've done it here
before, I can just
write what will be that
frequency of oscillation
here, as we've seen many times.
And, by the way, throughout
my solving the problems here,
I do not differentiate frequency
and angular frequency, that you
can see which I'm talking about
is whether I'm using omega
or F. Omega is the
angular frequency,
and there's just a fact
of 2 pi between the two.
But I'll use, interchangeably,
I'll call this frequency.
So this frequency of one of
the normal modes is just k/m.
So we found one
normal mode frequency.
Let's look for another one.
We stare at this and we see,
sure, there is another one.
Another one is where I take,
simply, these two masses
and simultaneously pull
them out, in this mass,
away and let go.
Effectively, these two
will look like that.
It's as if I had a mass of
2m attached to a mass of 2m
by two springs, each
of spring constant k.
And as I pull this back, this
will oscillate like this.
Everything, both this
mass and this mass,
will be oscillating with the
same frequency, same phase,
although there's
this minus sign.
I can always replace the
180-degree phase shift
by saying the
amplitude is minus.
So those are
identical statements.
So you have these two masses
oscillating like that.
OK?
By the way, I've said
that in the normal mode
I want everything to move
with the same frequency.
Some of you may argue, hold on.
Did I cheat on you?
Here, this mass is
not oscillating.
So am I contradicting myself?
And the answer is no.
It's a diabolical answer.
But I'll say, no,
this is oscillating
with this frequency,
but with 0 amplitude.
And you can't tell
me that I'm wrong.
It's not moving because
the amplitude is 0,
but it is oscillating
with the same frequency.
So now, what is the frequency
of this oscillation?
Again, I can do it in my head.
I can imagine that the middle
of this spring is not moving.
And so this mass is a half
a length of the spring
and a mass 2 attached
to it oscillating,
and I can calculate
the frequency
of oscillation of that.
Or if you prefer, I
can do the following.
I can move this mass out a
distance dx and this one dx
to the other side
and calculate what
will be the restoring force.
Well, now each one has
a spring constant k.
There is two of
them, so that's 2k.
Although this mass has been
moved by dx, this by dx,
the springs have been extended
by twice dx, so it's 2 dx.
So that's the total
restoring force
by Hooke's law, which
is equal minus 4k dx.
All right?
And so this will behave
like a single mass,
like this system, a single
mass with a single spring
where the spring has
a spring constant 4k.
The mass is 2m.
And so the angular frequency, or
frequency of this mode is 2k/m.
So we've found two of them.
Now, we know from our studies
of coupled oscillators
that for a system of
3 degrees of freedom,
so it would be three masses,
there are three normal modes.
What is the third normal mode?
And I intentionally
did not write it
down here because I wanted
you for a second to think.
Well, how else can
this system move such
that every mass is moving in
phase with the same frequency?
All right?
And I tell you,
when I first saw it,
it took me a long
time to figure out,
and most people don't find it.
And yet the answer
is extremely simple.
This answer is there is
one more normal mode.
It is one of almost infinite
amplitude, but 0 frequency.
Just the opposite to here,
where this was 0 amplitude, OK,
and the angular frequency
doesn't even matter.
Here it has very large
amplitude, infinite in fact,
but 0 frequency.
What does such motion look
like at any instant of time?
It's moving with
the same velocity.
So if I take and if I
consider the motion where
each one of these is moving
uniformly to the right
with a constant
velocity, that is
a normal mode with 0 frequency.
So the last one is
omega C is equal to 0.
OK?
So we have now found
the three normal modes.
OK.
All right.
Now that I've got a piece
of chalk, let's continue.
So we've answered the first
part of the question, what
are the normal mode
frequencies of the system?
And I found you those
three normal modes.
Now, the next question
we want to answer
is, if, at any given
instant of time,
I know the positions and the
velocities of the three masses,
can I predict what
will happen at the end?
That's equivalent
of saying, can I
write equations for the
positions of the masses
as a function of time?
For that I need to define for
myself a coordinate system.
So I'll say those are
those three masses.
All the motion is
along the x direction,
so there's just one variable,
one variable for each mass, x.
So the position
of the first mass
I'll call x1, position
of the second mass x2,
and of the third is x3.
And the origin of
coordinates I will
take to be through the
center of each mass
at a time when these
are in equilibrium.
In other words, the spring
is unstretched, et cetera.
OK.
So I can now, using the
information we've obtained,
write down the description
of each mass in each mode.
So in mode A, I know that
the x1 is 0 all the time.
It's not moving, OK?
Now, in a normal mode, that's
what we mean by a normal mode,
each mass is moving
with the same frequency
and the same phase,
and it's oscillating.
So there will be some sinusoidal
function of the mode frequency
t plus this phase times
some arbitrary amplitude.
The other one, the
last one, will also
be oscillating in
the normal mode,
so everything will be the same.
It will be cosine of
omega A t plus phi
A with some other amplitude.
But from our analysis
here, we know
that these two are
not both arbitrary.
Because we said that
in the normal mode,
it was the case where the
2m mass was stationary,
but these were going like this.
That was the first mode.
So whenever this one was going
to the right a distance A,
this one was going to
the left a distance A.
So the overall
normalization is arbitrary.
It can be anything.
But these are not
independent of the other,
because we discovered
that in that mode,
this was the frequency,
and the amplitudes were
opposite to each other.
So this describes the
situation for this system
if it's oscillating in
the first normal mode.
It's the most general
description of that.
Next, I will
describe what it will
do in the second normal mode.
And now I can go much quicker.
This time, it'll have
the second normal mode
frequency, different phase.
But these have to be the same
because all of these masses
are moving in the same normal
mode, same normal frequency.
These amplitudes,
overall, it's arbitrary.
I can make it anything.
It'll satisfy the equations.
But I know that in the
second normal mode,
this one is moving in that
direction and those two
in the opposite direction
with the same magnitude.
So these two have to have
the same size and magnitude,
but this has to be opposite.
So this describes the
motion in the second mode.
And finally, in the
third normal mode,
we said that it was 0 frequency.
All right?
And all that was
happening, the three masses
were moving with
uniform velocity.
So the positions
will be some constant
plus the velocity
of that system.
So this describes the
system in the third mode,
and these are the other two.
Now, I know that, in general,
each one of these masses
can move in a superposition
of the normal modes.
So the most general
expression for x1 of t
has to be of the form which is
the sum of its possible motion
in each of the modes.
So x1, so this is
the mass 2m, will
have possible motion in
the first mode, which is 0.
All right?
So I'll write 0 plus B times
cosine omega B t plus phi
B, all right, plus
C plus v. So that
will be the most general
description of the motion
of the big mass, the 2m one.
The B is arbitrary,
this phase is arbitrary,
this is arbitrary, and
v. Those quantities
will be determined by
the initial conditions.
Well, how about x2?
Well, I know that if x1 is
0, x2 is A cosine omega A t
plus phi A. When the x1 is this,
then x2 is minus B cosine omega
B t plus phi B, OK,
and plus C plus v. OK?
And finally, x3 of t,
again now just following
the same pattern, this is
minus A cosine omega A t
plus phi A. This one is
minus B cosine omega B
t plus phi B plus C plus v.
And I'm almost home.
I have described the
motion of each one.
For each particle,
it is oscillating
in a superposition
of its normal modes.
And the amplitudes are
arbitrary within the constraint
that the ratios between
them is determined
by the constraints
of the system.
So now the question is,
can I predict the future?
Well, in order to
predict the future,
say, where will
particle 3 be at time t?
I need to know the value of
these arbitrary constants.
Omega is not an
arbitrary constant.
We found it.
Omega A is here.
OK?
This is arbitrary, this is
arbitrary, this, and that.
So there are six
arbitrary constants.
How do I find them?
They are determined by
the initial conditions.
And you know,
fortunately, or else it
would mean we've made a mistake,
we have three conditions.
At the beginning,
someone has to tell me
where each mass was, the
location, and with what
velocity is it
moving at that time.
So I can write these
three equations at, say,
with t equals 0, at t
equals 0, and equate this
to the position of x1 of t
equals 0, wherever it is.
When the t is 0, I make it
equal to the position of x2 at t
equals 0.
When t is 0, this tells me has
to be equal to where x3 is.
That's three equations.
I can differentiate
each with respect
to time to get the
velocities, and likewise,
get three more equations.
So I'm going to end up with
six algebraic equations.
And you, as well as
I, know that if we
have six algebraic equations,
I can solve for six unknowns.
And that will give me
those six unknowns.
So once I've used the
initial conditions,
I can then find these
arbitrary constants.
They're no longer arbitrary
for a specific situation.
And I can predict the future,
what will happen in this case.
OK?
So that's the way one
would solve a problem when
you are lucky
enough that there is
sufficient symmetry in
the original situation
so you can guess
the normal modes.
The next problem I'll do, I will
do one where you cannot guess
the normal modes.
What do you do under
those circumstances?
And you won't be
surprised that it's
going to be mathematically much,
much harder, but conceptually
no harder.
So now we'll move
to the next problem.
Here it is.
But in order to be able
to do this problem,
I need more board space.
So we're going to erase the
boards and continue from there.
OK.
So now let's go and
do the second problem.
And it's going to be a
problem with no symmetry,
so we can't guess the
answer like we did before.
And I'll tell you
what I decided to do.
You remember
Professor Walter Lewin
in his lectures discussed
a double pendulum.
In other words,
a situation where
you had a string, a mass,
another string, and mass.
He gave you the answer,
but he didn't prove it.
He said it's hard and
lengthy, et cetera.
And I thought that would
be a perfect example
to do here from
first principles.
So let me just
describe in detail
the problem we're
trying to solve.
What we have is, again,
an idealized situation.
We have a simple pendulum
with a string of length L,
attached to it a mass m.
Attached to this mass at one
end is another string of length
L to another mass m.
We'll again idealize
the situation.
So the assumptions
we are making,
that this string and this string
is massless, which, by the way,
is equivalent to saying that
it's taut and straight all
the time.
You can think about
that for yourself.
Next, these masses
are point masses.
And we're assuming no friction.
Furthermore, as we've
done in the past,
we'll assume that
all displacements
when this is oscillating, at all
times the angle that the string
makes with the vertical is
always such that we can ignore
the difference between
a sine theta, theta,
or [INAUDIBLE] can make the
assumption that cosine theta is
0.
By the way, the fact that
we'll make this assumption
is equivalent to
saying that we'll
ignore vertical motion
of these masses.
The motion is sufficiently
small that vertically the masses
are not moving.
We can assume the acceleration
vertically is 0, et cetera.
OK?
This is in the vertical plane.
Gravity is down.
OK?
And what we are trying
to derive for this,
predict what are the normal
mode frequencies of this.
And once we do
that, of course, we
can use the same kind of
technique as we did before.
Once we've managed to
find the normal modes
and the frequencies,
we can always
write the most
general expression.
And then using the boundary
conditions, initial conditions,
predict what this will
do as a function of time.
OK, so let's get going.
OK.
Now, we are not guessing.
We are not using logic.
We are following the
kind of prescription
I've told you in the past.
This is our description
of the situation.
And all the new words
and ordinary language, we
must now translate
it into mathematics.
We've got to
describe this problem
in terms of
mathematical equations.
So step one is we
redraw this and define
some coordinate system.
So we will say that the
angle this first string makes
with respect to the
vertical is theta 1.
This angle the second
string makes with respect
to the vertical is theta 2.
We will take the vertical
through this pivot
here as our origin
of coordinate x.
x equals 0 here,
is defined here.
From the point of your
motion of the masses,
it's a one-dimensional problem.
The masses only move
along the x-axis.
So we'll define
this distance as x1,
and we'll define
this distance as x2.
Now we have to use the laws of
physics, Newtonian mechanics,
to derive the equations of
motion for the two masses.
So I draw a force diagram
separately for the two masses.
So the mass is there, what
forces act on that mass?
Well, I have to look at the mass
and see what's attached to it.
There is a string
here attached to it.
It's taut, so there
will be a tension in it.
So along this string,
there will be tension T1,
which will exert a force
T1 along this string.
This string is
attached to that mass.
It has a tension, so it's
pulling on this mass.
That tension I call
T2, so there will
be a force along
that direction T2.
This sits in a
gravitational field.
Gravity acts on this mass.
There is a force downwards
due to gravity, Fg.
The sum of these forces,
by Newton's laws,
must equal to the mass
times the acceleration.
That acceleration, in this
approximation that is not
moving up, is
horizontally, and it's
the second derivative of x1.
Similarly, for the second mass,
again, I'll go now faster.
There is this mass
m, and this tension
exerts a force here of T2
and the gravity on it Fg.
The only subtlety
is, why did I say
this force is equal
to that force?
Think about it for a second.
Why should the two
forces be equal?
Why is the tension at both
ends of the string equal?
And the answer is,
actually, a subtle one.
It's equal because we made the
assumption that the string has
no mass, and there can be no net
force on an object of 0 mass.
Because if there was, that
object would disappear,
would have an
infinite acceleration.
So if you treat the
string as a mass,
there cannot be net force on it.
And so the force of
each of these masses
must be pulling on this string
with exactly the same force
equal and opposite.
OK?
And we're using the third
law to equate those forces.
So the net result is this
T2 is the same as that,
but in opposite direction,
and this is the mass of that.
OK.
So these are the force diagrams.
Using now Newton's
laws of motion,
I can translate this
into equations of motion.
So let me consider
the horizontal motion
of each mass separately.
First this mass, and so
its mass times acceleration
is equal to the
horizontal force of T2.
And remember that this
angle here is theta 2.
And we see that the
force due to T2,
and there's a T2 sine theta 2.
And the force due to T1
is minus T1 sine theta 1
because it's in the
opposite direction.
For this, the only
horizontal component
is the force horizontal
component of T2.
And x2 double dot is equal
to minus T2 sine theta 2.
OK, that's horizontal motion.
Applying Newton's laws of
motion to the vertical motion,
we said that, because cosine
theta is 0 or approximately 0,
the masses are not
moving up and down.
There's no acceleration
of the masses.
So the vertical acceleration
of the first mass
is 0 must be equal to the
vertical component of T1, which
is T1 cosine theta 1, minus
the vertical component of this,
which is minus T2
cosine theta 2 minus mg.
All right.
Similarly for the second
mass, it's 0 is equal to this.
0 must equal to the
vertical component
of T1 minus the
vertical component of T2
minus the force of gravity down.
And similarly for
the second mass,
we know that vertically
the acceleration is 0.
That must be equal to the
vertical component of T2
minus the gravitational
force pulling down.
Now I can make use of what we
made the assumption-- oops,
I see there is an error.
If you were in this
room, I'm sure you
would have corrected me.
For very small angles,
the sine of an angle
is approximately
equal to the angle.
But for small angles,
the cosine is 1.
This is an error, and
I apologize for that.
But that's the
approximation we are making.
And it is this
approximation which
is equivalent to saying that we
can ignore the vertical motion.
All right.
So with the assumption
that the cosines are all 1,
I can, from these two
equations, I clearly
derive that T2 must equal to
mg, and T1 equals twice mg.
Actually, it makes sense.
Imagine this is hanging
completely vertically.
Obviously, this string, the
upper part of the string,
is supporting not only
this mass but also that.
It's supporting 2m masses,
while this string is only
supporting 1.
So that's consistent
with what we see,
that the top string has twice
the tension and the lower
one half the tension.
Having determined T1
and T2, we can now
go back into our equation,
replace the T1 and T2.
We also can replace--
we know what
sine theta 1 and
sine theta 2 are.
We can replace those.
And we end up--
the two equations
of motions are written here.
All right?
So here is the equation
of motion for x1.
And the second one, the
equation for motion of x2,
is written here.
OK?
So these are the
equations of motion,
all right, which
we have to solve.
Now, to simplify the algebra,
let me define the quantity g/l
by omega squared over 2.
And you'll recognize this.
This is not [INAUDIBLE].
I'm using that terminology.
This is the frequency
of oscillation
of a mass on a
string of length l.
All right?
So here are our two differential
equations, the two equations
of motion, one for
x1 and one for x2.
When we had one mass,
one harmonic oscillator,
we had a single second-order
differential equation.
We now have two
masses, so we have
two second-order
differential equations.
These are it.
They are coupled
differential equations.
You see, the derivatives of x1
is related both to x1 and x2.
The second derivative of x2 is
related both to x1 and to x2.
So these are two coupled
differential equations.
OK?
This is the end of step 1.
What we succeeded
in, we've translated
the physical situation
into mathematics.
These two second-order
differential equations
describe exactly that
idealized situation we had.
So if I now want to
answer the question, what
will be the motion
of those masses,
I have to go into the
world of mathematics.
I have to solve these equations.
And life is not
as easy as it was
for a single second-order
differential equation.
It's more complicated.
But here I will use
my general knowledge
of what happens when you
have coupled oscillators.
I know that the general
solution of coupled oscillations
is a superposition
of normal modes.
Here I have 2
degrees of freedom,
two second-order
differential equations.
There will be two normal modes.
If I succeed in
finding them, I will
have found the most general
solution to this problem,
because it will be the sum
of the two normal modes.
So I will now do it by trial.
In a normal mode,
we know that x1
will be oscillating
with a single frequency
omega, some phase phi,
some amplitude A1.
This will be a solution
to these equations.
If this is a solution
to those equations,
the other mass must
also be oscillating
in the same normal mode,
meaning with the same frequency
and same phase.
It'll have some
arbitrary amplitude.
So I don't know what A1 is,
and I don't know what omega is.
I don't know what phi is.
But I know that the
solutions to these equations
must be of this form.
OK?
So let me now try to find
these various constants.
Well, if this and that
satisfies these equations--
and it has to because
that's what it's saying,
these are the solutions
of those equations--
then I can take these, x1 and
x2, plug it into this equation.
In other words, calculate
the second derivative
of x1, et cetera,
calculate second,
and I'll end up
with two equations.
OK?
So I won't bother to go
in great detail here.
But just to start off
with, x1 double dot,
I have to differentiate
A1 cosine omega t twice.
So I get minus omega squared A1
times cosine omega t plus phi.
If I take the next term, I get
this, and the third term that.
And in each case, if
you notice, since it'll
be multiplied by the
same cosine function,
I've just canceled in my head
the cosine function there.
All right?
Just saving time.
Similarly, next equation,
I end up with this.
So if my guessed functions,
and I'm returning to this,
if these two satisfy
those equations,
then here these algebraic
equations must be satisfied.
But you'll notice
something interesting.
If I take the first
of these equations,
it boils down to A1 times
this quantity plus A2
to [? then ?] this
quantity equal to 0.
And the second equation
boils down to this.
If this is true, then
this must be true.
It's A1 divided by A2
has to be equal to that.
If this is true,
then A1 divided by A2
has got to be equal to this.
That means that this
has to be equal to that,
or else I have an inconsistency.
So what I have found is
that, in general, my guess
is not a good one.
In general, these
equations would not
satisfy my second-order
differential equations.
There is only under very
special circumstances
that they do
satisfy it, and that
is if this is equal to that.
In general, they
will not be equal.
So under what conditions
will these be equal?
Well, let me force them.
Let me say this is
equal to that and see
what it means for omega.
I originally took omega
to be an unknown quantity.
What I am now seeing,
that those functions
would work only for
specific values of omega.
So I'm going to solve
this equation for omega
and see for what values of omega
do I get a consistent solution.
And this is a hard
grind, unfortunately.
If I take this,
multiply it out, I
get a quadratic equation
in omega squared.
If this quadratic
equation is satisfied,
then all these are
self-consistent.
All right?
You know how to solve
a quadratic equation,
and this is a quadratic
equation in omega squared.
Omega square will have
to be equal to minus
this plus or minus the
square root of this,
4 times this times that,
divided by 2a, right?
This is the standard
formula for the solution
of a quadratic equation.
And there's a plus or minus.
If I calculate this out,
I get that omega squared
has to be equal
to 2 plus or minus
the square root of 2
times omega 0 squared.
All right?
Now, omega 0 squared, earlier
on, I defined to be g/l.
So omega squared has to be this.
So let's stop for
a second and think
and review what we've done.
We found that our
physical situation
can be described by these two
coupled differential equations.
We looked for solutions, which
are normal modes where both x1
and x2 is oscillating with
same frequency and phase.
And we found that it was
possible to find solution
of this form to these equations
if and only if omega squared
has one of two possible values.
I've rewritten them here.
One is 2 plus root 2
times g/l, and the other's
2 minus root 2 g/l.
With these values, these two
equations satisfies that.
So what we found is
the two normal modes.
Since this system consists
of the coupled oscillators,
in other words, two oscillators
coupled with each other,
we know there are
two normal modes.
So these are the normal mode
frequencies in this situation.
And by the way, I'm
delighted to see
that, if you remember Professor
Walter Lewin's lectures,
he actually quoted
these numbers.
So he was right.
He did not make a mistake,
as we've just seen.
OK?
These are the two
normal mode frequencies.
Now, how about if
we want to predict
everything, the
amplitude, et cetera?
We've got to be careful here
with the logic we've applied.
For any one of these normal
frequencies, say this one,
earlier on we found that A1 to
A2 is given by this equation
or by this equation.
But for the given
values of omega,
we found these are
now equivalent.
And so if you know what
omega is, say omega A,
one of the normal
modes, this we know.
It's g/l.
And this is known.
So A1/A2, once we fix
omega A, is fixed.
So these are not two
independent amplitudes.
So if I go back to here when
we said let's guess a solution,
and this was an arbitrary
number and this was an arbitrary
number, now we see
that in a normal mode
the ratio between them is fixed.
It depends on the
normal mode frequency.
But the [? overall ?]
normalization
is still arbitrary.
I could make this 10 times
this and 10 times that.
[? It  would still ?] work.
So back to here, we found one of
the normal mode's frequencies.
Using the equation
above, it determines
the value of A1 to A2.
Taking the other
normal mode frequency
determines the
ratio of those two
but not the overall amplitude.
Not to confuse the two, I
will call this B1 and B2.
This is the amplitude
of the first mass,
and this is of the other one.
The ratio is fixed, determined
by the value of omega B.
But the overall
amplitude is not.
So now we have ended up
in the same situation
we were in our three masses,
where, if you remember,
I started by guessing
the normal modes
and guessing the
relative amplitudes.
And with that information alone
and the initial conditions,
I could predict
what will happen.
I could now repeat that here.
But to save time, I think
you can do that for yourself.
For each, you can write
now a single equation
saying what a given mass will do
as the sum of two normal modes,
where you know the frequency
of them and the amplitudes.
And you have to remember
that for the two masses,
the ratio of the amplitudes
in each normal mode
have to be fixed given
by what we've done here.
And therefore, you can
get the single equation
for each mass, one for one
mass, one for the other.
Which will tell you what
they will do in the future
if you know what they're
doing initially, for example,
the initial conditions,
that you can solve
to get the final predicted
position of each mass.
So that's as much
as I was hoping
to do today on
coupled oscillators.
And we'll continue
next time on situations
with many, many more
degrees of freedom.
Thank you.